ما تزال قذائف اليورينيوم المنضب التي
تعهدت لندن بتزويد الجيش الاوكراني بها
تزيد من احتماليه تاجيج الصراع
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعتبرت ان استخدام
مثل هذه الذخيره سيسبب ضررا على الانسان
والزراعه في المناطق التي ستستخدم فيها
ضرر قد تكون نتائجه وخيبه وفقا لبرنامج
الامم المتحده للبيئه هذه الذخيره تعتبر
معدنا ثقيلا ساما كيميائيا واشعاعيا
والتعامل معها يجب ان يظل عند الحد الادنى
حيث يتطلب ارتداء الملابس الواقيه حسب
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه اليورينيوم
المنظم ليس خطرا اشعاعيه لكن استنشاق
جزيئاته قد يسبب تلفا كلويا كما ان انتقال
جزيئاته الى الانسان عبر المزروعات قد
يسبب امراضا سرطانيه
رغم ان ذخائر لورينيوم المنظم لا تعتبر
اسلحه نوويه انبعاثها لمستويات منخفضه من
الاشعاع دفع هيئه الرقابه النوويه التابعه
للامم المتحده الى توخي الحذر عند التعامل
معها والتحذير من مخاطرها وبدرجه روسيا
التي تساعد ضد استخدام قذائف اليورينيوم
متهمه باستخدامها على نطاق واسع في
اوكرانيا ومناطق اخرى ليبقى المدنيون
الخاسر الاكبر من هذه الاسلحه